Let's see how to install and use Google Cloud Tools extension
for Visual Studio
To install, go to tools, then extensions and updates in Visual Studio
Click on online and search for Google Cloud Platform extension
Once installed, it will show up under installed section
You can find the extension under Tools
and Google Cloud Tools. Before we can use the extension,
we need to add our account, so let's do that
Let's open Google Cloud Explorer and select our project from the list
Under Compute Engine, you can see status
or create a new Windows or Linux Compute Engine instance
You can also see different
regions/zones and perform some operations on instances in those regions
Under Cloud Storage, you can see the list of buckets
browse them by going to Cloud Console
Under Cloud SQL, you can see Cloud SQL instances
and create data connections to them. Thanks for watching!